Sa kabanatang ito, titingnan natin
kung paano magkasamang gumagana ang quantum at classical na mga computer
para malutas ang isa sa pinakamahalagang hamon
sa agham: ang tumpak na pagtatantya ng enerhiya ng mga molekula at materyales
Magagawa natin ito
sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng quantum circuit
para makagawa ng mga sample na halimbawa
na ipo-post-process natin
at ida-diagonalize gamit ang isang grupo ng mga algorithm
sa pamilyang ito ng mga routine
tulad ng SQV at SKG, at may buong kurso sa
IBM Quantum platform na nakatuon
para sa kanila at sa mga kaugnay na pamamaraan
Para sa ating layunin sa seksyong ito,
magiging maikli ang paliwanag
Hindi mahalaga kung SQV o SKG ang ginagamit mo—
ang layunin mo ay hanapin ang mga eigenvector
at eigenvalue ng isang Hamiltonian matrix
Ang matrix na ito ay maaaring maglalarawan ng enerhiya ng isang pisikal
o chemical na sistema, pero ang parehong framework
ay maaaring gamitin sa maraming ibang uri ng problema
tulad ng logistics. Minsan
ang mga matrix na ito ay napakalaki,
kaya ang pagbabawas ng dimensyon
ng matrix habang pinapanatili ang mahahalagang
katangian ng ground state
ay maaaring maging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang. Iyan ang layunin sa SQV.
Ginagamit natin ang quantum computer para makagawa ng kapaki-pakinabang na subspace—
isa na naglalaman ng ground state
Maaari nating i-project ang ating Hamiltonian matrix
sa subspace na iyon, at maiiiwan tayo
ng isang maliit na matrix na magiging
mas madaling i-diagonalize
gamit ang classical high performance computing. Ginagawa natin ito
sa pamamagitan ng paghahanda ng trial quantum state—
madalas na tinatawag na ansatz—
at pagsasagawa ng mga sukat para ma-sample ang ansatz na iyon
sa computational basis. Nagbibigay ito sa atin ng
isang sample na subspace sa computational basis,
pero ang talagang gusto nating mahanap
ay ang tunay na ground state. Paano
kung ang ating sample na subspace ay hindi naglalaman
ng lahat ng kinakailangang bahagi?
Kung pipili tayo ng mas magandang ansatz,
maaari tayong makakuha ng mas magandang tantya ng ground state.
Dinadala tayo niyan sa sample-based
Krylov quantum diagonalization, o SKQD. Sa SKQD,
nagsisimula tayo sa isang ansatz
tulad ng dati, pero nagdadagdag tayo ng ilang quantum gate na humahawad sa
time evolution ng isang pisikal na sistema.
Maaaring ipakita na sa ilang pagpapalagay,
ito ay nagdudulot ng mga garantiya sa overlap sa pagitan ng time-evolved
na ansatz at ng tunay na ground state.
Ang parehong mga algorithm na ito ay nagsisimula sa napakalaking
Hamiltonian matrix. Nagtatrabaho sila nang medyo magkaiba,
pero sa parehong kaso, ang quantum na bahagi ng algorithm ay nagbubunga ng
isang subspace na nagpapahintulot sa atin na paikliin ang ating matrix—
kung saan umaasa tayong mapangalagaan ang mga pangunahing katangian ng ground state.
Kaya saan pumapasok ang high performance classical computing
para sa pinakamalaking mga Hamiltonian
at para sa pinaka-tumpak na mga tantya ng ground state?
Kahit ang mga projected na matrix na ito ay maaaring medyo malaki.
Kaya naman, ang paggamit ng mas makapangyarihang classical na computing capabilities
ay makakatulong sa atin—hindi lang
para makakuha ng mas magandang resulta,
kundi pati na rin sa pag-tackle ng mas malalaking problema.
Para pagsamahin ang lahat,
maaari nating katawanin ang mga sample-based na algorithm
bilang kombinasyon ng iba't ibang programming model
sa isang hanay ng heterogeneous na resources.
Halimbawa, maaari nating katawanin ang ating algorithm
bilang isang task workflow kung saan magkakaroon tayo ng task
para sa quantum circuit preparation na may overlap
sa ating target state, na sinusundan ng isang task
para sa transpilation na nangangailangan lamang ng classical na resources
para ma-execute. Kasunod nito ang task
na gumagamit ng primitives para i-execute ang ating quantum circuit,
na siyempre ay nangangailangan ng quantum na resources,
at pagkatapos ay magkakaroon ng post-processing task na maaaring maging
isang parallel na diagonalization algorithm
na tumatakbo sa maraming node.
Bukod dito, maaari tayong gustong patakbuhin
ang isa sa mga algorithm na ito nang maraming beses
habang binabago natin ang ating ansatz,
o patakbuhin ang mga ito nang sabay-sabay
na may iba't ibang parameters.
Ngayon, pagsamahin nating lahat gamit ang SKQD
sa code. Narito ang lahat ng ating task files,
at narito ang lahat ng ating submission files.
Sa mapping task, naghahanda tayo ng mga circuit.
Sa optimization step, pinapatakbo natin ang mga circuit sa pinakamainam na paraan.
Sa execution task, nagsa-sample tayo ng mga bitstring
mula sa state na inihanda ng
ating ISA circuit.
Ito ang makukuha natin mula sa nakaraang hakbang,
at doon natin ginagawa ang ating post-processing.
Kaya handa na tayong i-submit ang ating
SKQD workflow.
Tulad ng makikita mo, lahat ay tumatakbo nang sunud-sunod
na may mga dependencies. Hintayin natin
ang mga resulta at maaari nating suriin ang ating output files.
Narito ang output file ng optimization step,
kung saan makikita natin ang ating ISA circuit.
At tingnan na rin natin ang ating end-of-
iteration na output.
Mula sa iskedyul.
At iyon na ang mabilis na demonstrasyon ng SKQD workflow.
Lahat ng code ay makukuha sa text section
o sa description sa ibaba.
At iyon na! Tinahak na natin ang ilang
konsepto at halimbawa na makakatulong sa iyong makapagsimula sa
pamamahala ng mga kumplikadong hybrid na programa. Siyempre,
kung gusto mo, bahagi pa lamang ito ng
lahat ng magagawa mo sa kombinasyon ng quantum
at classical na resources. Para mas malaman pa,
tingnan ang dokumentasyon at mga tutorial
sa IBM Quantum platform,
at huwag kalimutang tingnan ang mga resources na nakalagay sa text section
o description para sa karagdagang tools
at software. Salamat sa panonood!
Yeah.